that's you that's you this is me we
rehearsed it for a month
so instead of reacting i'm talking about
the stunts and i'm reacting to stunts
but like i'm not a stuntman so there's
like a little bit of this
imposter feeling so today i'm going to
be doing the high fall
this is the kind of stuff you see in
films where you know something gets
thrown out of the window or it has to
take a big leap this is a real stunt and
we're going to be jumping off the top of
this building
travis wong has joined us he's an
awesome stunt coordinator and stunt man
himself
he is going to be guiding me through the
process of doing
a high fall this is going to be really
fascinating i'm a little nervous
i'm a little scared i'm also really
excited most importantly
i don't want to embarrass myself in
front of the stuntman
[Laughter]
hey everybody today is a big day for me
because i'm going to be jumping off the
roof of this building we're going to get
up there with some help
of travis wong here and solomon as well
walk me through a little bit about
what to expect today so a highfall is
unique in the sense that it's not only
relying upon having to
safely fall to the ground but you're
also adding in the extra element of
height
so today we're going to basically just
take you through the gamut of how to
safely progress from
ground level falls work our way up to a
little bit more elevation and then
eventually i think we're going to jump
off the roof
you are the stunt coordinator in this
situation here what is a stunt
coordinator what is your job a stunt
coordinator is the person who generally
speaking is in charge of speaking with
all departments you're in charge of
hiring the stunt team
you're in charge of working closely with
the director in production about making
sure everything happens
and most importantly you're just there
to make sure that the safety of the crew
and the cast
is the number one priority and we're
joined by solomon as well so
why do you need another guy to help out
solomon's here to lend his expertise in
rigging so we have some elements today
where we'll use him to utilize rigging
some stuff to safely keep you secure
we're going to set up the system to be
as safe as possible and keep you safe
but you are going to have to stay very
very present remember all of the steps
that we take from the ground level all
the way up
because like we said stunts inherently
is risky me and solomon are here to
completely eliminate all those factors
so that we get invited back
minimize the margin for error is what
we're trying to do it's going to be
really intense
and we're going to take you guys along
on the entire journey so let's go
so while they're setting up right now i
think it's a good time for us to just
warm your body up so the first thing you
do today isn't
hitting the ground uh so we'll take you
through a little warm-up and just get
your blood pumping okay sounds good cool
so unfortunately when we're on set most
times it's usually a game of like hurry
up
and wait around and then when you get
called you're like i'm completely cold
right now
so when we have the option to warm up we
warm up
man this is my yates riggers harness a
little bit overkill but
it's certainly the most appropriate gear
to have on set
and this is what you have to wear if
you're up in the perms in these big
studio buildings
you have to have this on for safety at
all times
show me what i gotta do show me how to
fall on the ground
so luckily for you this should be more
of a review than a lesson actually
i actually saw the video where gee was
teaching you guys some basic falls front
fall
side fall and a backfall and uh we're
only going to use one of those today
okay let's focus right now on just
refreshing and reviewing
a backfall we'll just start here and we
go
one you want to make sure that you tuck
your chin so you don't hit your head
back
and secondly most important is when you
go down to the ground you want to have
points of contact to help displace the
weight
so generally speaking that will be arms
in a spread position like this
keeping your head off of the ground from
tucking and then you can also utilize
your feet i know geek kind of showed you
some of this press up i'll give it a
shot
first of all the day we're gonna screw
this one up if it's gonna go wrong goes
wrong on this one
generally speaking
amazing i saw that chin tub too
so on this round let's start with one
foot in front of the other
swing one leg to generate that height
and then you do the same exact ball see
now
i start thinking about what side do i
use and then i'm like i don't know what
side i use i start overthinking it i
have a test for that okay can i show you
the test
what we're doing is we're throwing you
off balance and we just like to see
which foot you feel safe with saving
yourself
oh you may be left
[Applause]
you may be left all right swing that leg
out nico
yes brother so good so the test works
you guys see what happens the test
worked
i would just love to add in maybe a
couple of steps so you just start
getting used to adding a little bit of
forward momentum but when you go
a natural tendency is for people to
swing and allow their head to go just
make sure to keep that chin tucked
[Music]
super good anytime i think about my
steps i forget about my arms like which
arms so now what we're gonna do is build
towards a header
which eventually will be you taking off
from the roof and initiating basically
half to three quarters of a front flip
and then essentially landing on your
back
round one i would love for you to just
do a forward roll okay
good job
i mean that looks pretty easy it's very
i don't want to assume that it is but
we can take it to the next level now so
i'm going to lay down this apple box and
then just to avoid slipping just because
as we said safety is always the biggest
concern
we knew some of these rubber inserts
from our buddies over at action factory
and this will actually stop it from
sliding one foot goes down and then you
will initiate
the roll as your right foot starts to
swing up behind you okay
[Applause]
raising my self-esteem little by little
all right so we're gonna eliminate your
hands now so we're really focused on
utilizing our hips right now right this
is kind of like your fulcrum so as long
as you put that head down swing the
right leg
you will get around you make it look so
clean
yes all right thank you
look at that it's like an official
snowfall to go through your stunt shirt
now yeah i know i know
that's right that's why tom cruise
always wears black t-shirts all the time
we'll just remember all these little
tips guys
moving on to the neck all right so i
jumped onto the little skinny pad now
we're gonna
step it up a little bit and we're gonna
jump onto this pad here what we're using
now is what's known as a porta pit or a
resin pin
what they allow for is you to take much
higher falls with less risk factor
because they're so much softer
yeah the other was like a good whiplash
simulator you know
now the most important thing about all
of these falls we do from here on out is
making sure that you get enough distance
to clear your takeoff point
so let's always aim to try to get our
butt to right around where that seam is
if that makes sense makes sense all
right cool so when you're starting off
it is always great to reverse engineer
things so go to your start point and
then literally reverse your steps
and then i always tell people to add on
an extra half step because when you have
adrenaline you'll take a bigger step if
that's that's a really good tip
exactly so
good job man good job really good job
all right thank you
so you killed that one i think now let's
work on the header so on this one you
almost want to use momentum to help you
fall into it if that makes sense
so what we'll do is we'll line your feet
up again same thing you'll get to the
edge you start to lean and then just a
little bit of initiation
with your left foot and your right swing
the thing i like about the header is
that
i can spot this ledge not doing a blind
kind of back to it you know on this one
just bend your knees a little bit of
load and then lean in
nice super good good thank you a little
quicker exactly so if you feel good with
this
our next goal would basically be to take
these mats inside and then
have you jump off a much higher takeoff
point before we take it to the roof
okay let's do it let's try and do a
little extra securing of this
to make sure it doesn't even move an
inch when you're standing up on top of
it could you be surprised a tiny little
shift of a half inch when you're
standing
up there confidence gone
this is my first leg slightly high fall
but still into the porter pitch before
like
jumping into a cloud so yeah this part's
nice
so as you can see we have a frame ladder
here and then using pieces of tech right
now this is
secured to this so that we don't have
wiggle room when you're taking off and
then most importantly we have
fastened this half apple box to the top
it's not only wedged between the
pressure of the ladder itself but it's
also ratcheted strap down
and this will give you a good surface
area to take off on and then when you
feel good i think the first thing we
should do is the backfall
there's going to be a couple of factors
you need to make sure that you're aware
of you need to make sure you don't over
rotate on the header
and you also need to make sure that you
clear enough space that you don't fall
on the ladder itself
so i think this is going to be a really
really crucial drill before we take you
up to the roof and uh based on the way
things are going so far
i think you'll be good so if you guys
have ever seen a high fall done
especially to an airbag you're probably
wondering why we're not having nikko
land fully flat like this
i'm having niko purposely bend his legs
for these three reasons because he's
never done stunts one we have brand new
boxes are going to be held very firmly
together
and he runs the risk of hurting his leg
on a hard edge like this
secondly if he comes down at a weird
angle he could potentially hyper extend
his legs if they're straight
and the third reason is that a lot of
times when people tend to lay flat
they get really lazy and they don't tuck
their chin and they hit their head like
this
the first thing i want you to do is when
you're up there is i want you to squat
so that you can lower your eye line and
take away that fear yeah it's like it
feels like four or five feet but when
you stand up your brain is going to play
tricks on you right so all i want you to
do is think about how you're going to do
the fall from that position
and then when you stand back up just do
the same exact motion
all right here we go three two one
he's alive all right
good i'm feeling good travis is really
making me feel like i'm doing a good job
he's really nice to me um if you're cool
with it i would love to try a header
let's do it
let's also play into the fact that
because we have height now let's try not
to jump
the worst thing that could happen on a
header is if you jump too hard
you'll actually initiate a front flip
and you'll go past your back
so if anything just fall into it keep
that chin tucked and you'll be all good
you okay
nice all right you honestly do look
comfortable with this one comparative to
the flat back you can do this all day
dudes all day so we're at a very
interesting point right now
because we have done ground falls we've
done our medium falls now
pretty much only leaves us high falls
how are you feeling at this point i'm
feeling really good
i'm honestly super excited to jump off
the roof
i think the next step at this point
would be to start building our box
catcher
padding you up physically and then just
going over some of the things like you
said of what to expect when you actually
make contact with the boxes okay
we are building the box pit that nika's
about to jump into
from that roof niko's life is all just
put into the hands of these cardboard
boxes this is nico's life
in your hands jordan you gotta make sure
these boxes are secure come on
right now they're in the process of just
building the boxes themselves just to
formulate having them but we're actually
gonna have to go down and build a box
catcher physically how high do you think
the boxes will be
ideally i believe we're gonna go four
layers up okay
all right so things are going really
well we're getting ready to do the final
jump here so we're just gonna grab some
more boxes from the studio and put
another layer on top so that niko is
extra safe while doing the stunt
they're already built sweet take that
dude jake
nick i'm defending my fort what are you
doing here quickly come quickly is this
a brand deal
thing have an entrance wow welcome to my
squarespace courtesy of today's sponsor
squarespace my name is lord brandywine
of the o'daniel clan
and we really need these boxes for the
video shoot i went to see the lady of
the square pond
she put a curse on me but for the rest
of my life i must tell everyone
every chance that i get about beautiful
award-winning templates
squarespace has beautiful award-winning
templates
and much like i used these boxes to put
together piece by piece this beautiful
hall
squarespace will allow you to build a
beautiful website
using their templates if you see over
here
i messed up i was going to write ye old
for squarespace but then i realized
i wasn't doing it in my native
font if i would have used squarespace's
multiple contributors tool somebody else
on my team would have pointed it out
multiple people on your creative team
can do exactly that they can
take part in your website numerous ways
a team makes everything better
now just like i have a view over my
entire domain
squarespace's traffic overviews features
will give you an overview
of your entire domain who comes who goes
what pages they visit
all kinds of good information you can
use to improve your domain
just like i've cordoned off the swamp to
protect me from the lady of the lake
you can cordon off your domain with
members areas on squarespace
and have people sign up for memberships
via your subscription service it's
pretty great now if you're interested in
getting started with your own website
consider going to squarespace.comcrew
and you too
can have your own brandio daniel clan
the klansmen of the lake
nico's about to jump off the roof we
need the boxes
okay hey what if i bring you a perfectly
square shrubbery in exchange for these
boxes
perfectly square the curse
is being lifted
[Music]
what's going on jake yeah we got to get
these boxes out to niko what are you
guys doing
[Music]
come on if he were to jump into this he
would die oh did jordan do this work
it's amazing there's some times when
you're in this business and you're like
i'm on a 100 million dollar feature film
and i'm about to jump into cardboard
boxes there's just some things that have
stood through all time
because they're just techniques that
have worked the most important thing
though with building these box catchers
is a
ensuring that you have enough tension by
bounding them together with a rope
we want to have the boxes really really
tight so that when you hit they don't
just completely explode and then the
second most important thing is also
ensuring that the boxes are in the right
position
as well as adding flats so that you
don't just have the ability to fly all
the way straight through
so we're just making sure that we build
a large enough catcher so the niko
doesn't have to
over think about aiming if that makes
sense so that he can just worry about
performing to the best of his ability
ready yeah man i'm ready
[Music]
as you can see we have built our
official box catcher right now and it's
pretty considerably larger than the pads
that you fell to inside so i think
you'll have a huge area to aim for
if you just are confident in the things
that we worked over the last couple of
hours
and you just remember everything and
have fun that's gonna be over before you
know it
got it so remember everything we
practice two have fun
third safety right safety come through
don't screw up
we're all set up on our end if you feel
good then i think the next thing to do
is just
get your final preparation set and uh
let you have some fun sweet
all right excited have fun i will let's
do this bro boom thanks travis
big target it is it's bigger than inside
i'm gonna do a front tuck i think
yeah we like to call it a header for a
high fall but uh yeah he's gonna
basically do
almost a half front flip to his back
this is for real
for living for experience call back
everybody
camera set all right niko are you set
set all right guys here we go on my cue
in three two one
action
[Music]
oh my god
yo amazing landing look where you are
perfect aim bro
i'm so relaxed
how'd it go good i'm just going to chill
here for a little bit
that was fun how did it feel how are
your arms arms are great
body's great like really not a single
scratch honestly the impact
the practice one was harder than this
one the more impact the more momentum
just pulls you right through the box it
doesn't feel as much of an impact all
right so this is the funniest part guys
he just did the coolest most epic badass
fall ever
and now getting out of it he's going to
look like a toddler
nico i want you to know that in your
final moment sam started laughing at you
well when you hit it it was such like
the thump was so just
conclusive
yeah you want to see the replay yeah the
hardest part's the jump you know it's
like okay you gotta do it all smoothly
and remember it yeah
it's good for it man you fell into it no
jumping
that must be the weird part when you're
upside down that's sweet
you're still good on the form your legs
were in the perfect position you hit
your back
beautiful man yeah it really helps when
you
like tie the boxes together like tightly
so when you hit it they don't just
explode everywhere and you go straight
to the bottom
yeah so you absolutely killed the header
which i expected i know that was the one
you're most confident in
i know this one where we go to the back
you're a little less sure of so i think
let's eliminate the variable of you
running into it
and let's just have you start stationary
on top of the platform and then we'll
just go three
two one ultimate trust ball
yeah i have a really good sense of like
how far i traveled now and the speed of
it the only way to get better at is by
more reps so at this point you got more
high fall reps than anyone else in the
crew so
nico aim for that center mark tuck that
chin all right we got it here we go
in three two one action
nico you good we got the thumbs up baby
two for two
i don't know if he went as deep on that
one i think only one layer of boxes but
a wider displacement of area
so that means i did a better job yeah i
think you just spread out your surface
area better
that's awesome and that one's weird that
one's like unnatural for me to spin that
way
i know it's really weird to just jump
and then commit to leaning backwards
yeah
yeah man you did it man thank you now
you got on the camera forever don't
gotta do it again
he has landed dude you killed it nice
work
damn i'm alive that one was definitely
like a little more thrilling
and a little more scary it's not a
natural rotation it's harder to like
adjust
but i did it here i am oh we just jumped
off the roof and landed here in this
segment
i'm still alive still in peace actually
no bumps scratches or bruises
i think the thing that really helped
more than anything is just going through
those levels of progression
if we had started with you right on the
rooftop you probably would have been
full of
i wouldn't freaked out no i think the
real thing that it comes down to is just
preparation and the team that you have
if you surround yourself with good
people a good team a good coordinator
and good performers the end result is
always going to be something that's
really memorable and something that's
most likely going to last on film
forever
yeah it's super cool so if you guys
happen to be in the la area travis along
with aaron have a gym that they run
called jam yeah it's in the san fernando
valley merceda we're a stunt gym that
also teaches parkour tricking tumbling
and we also have open gyms for anyone
interested
j movement for the gym and then if you
want to visit me personally it's just
the
travis swan we also have a youtube
channel here recorder crew
feel free to subscribe if you're not hey
but seriously i'd really appreciate it
it helps us out so
this is an awesome experience solomon
travis you killed it
thank you so much guys great work this
is awesome thanks for having us yeah
i guess the rest of days can be really
boring now see you guys later